sara is with us in Denver hi Sarah how
are you good thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I am wondering about
bankruptcy I didn't think we would end
up here but sure enough we are we
previously already had about 82 thousand
dollars in debt and then I had a medical
emergency with no insurance that put me
in the hospital
and now on top of that 80 mm I have a 65
thousand dollar medical bill so that was
around a hundred and forty seven
thousand dollars in debt and I didn't
calculate our take-home pay but adjusted
gross income is only about eighty
thousand okay and and what is the other
eighty thousand dollars in debt break it
down for me
I have 27 thousand in credit card debt
we have forty two thousand and two car
loans sixty-eight hundred in a signature
loan seven hundred and a personal loan
and we still have $600 on cellphones
okay no student loans no a few months
okay all right well there's two kinds of
bankruptcy chapter 13 and chapter 7 that
are primarily available to somebody in
your situation chapter 13 is where you
pay a payment plan and everyone gets
repaid some or all of what they are owed
but they are kept under control why you
do that to keep them from suing you or
taking something or garnishing your
wages or that kind of stuff okay the the
second type of bankruptcy is called a
chapter 7 and that's what we usually
think of when we think of bankruptcy and
it's the atom bomb dropped on it it's
the clean slate okay and under a chapter
7 you're allowed to keep a certain
amount of personal assets and your home
your personal exemption it's called it's
different from state to state I don't
know what it is in Colorado it's
typically around ten thousand dollars
worth of stuff which mutually means like
you know your used furniture in your
house you could keep do you own your
home we don't or renting so we're
definitely thinking chapter 13 because
we need to keep a vehicle we have
a big family so we could probably sell
one of the vehicles but the other
vehicles a passenger van it's not like
we could sell it and buy a car we
wouldn't be able to transport everybody
so you have a large family we do myself
and my husband and we have seven
children okay
so chapter chapter seven in a chapter
seven as well going back to that you can
you can only keep secured assets if you
agree to pay them so you technically
could file in 90 something percent of
cases you could file a chapter 7 wipe
off everything that you've given me
except the cars or car if you want to
turn in one of the cars you could but
you can reaffirm the debt if the lender
will allow it and most of the time they
will reaffirm the debt and so you would
just pick back up and keep paying the
payment if you don't pay the payment you
don't get to keep the lien the house
whatever it is as a lien against it so
you're going to come out of this with
one car or two cars with debt against
them regardless of which type of
bankruptcy you go through okay so that's
all a possibility and they do what's
called a means test which is a
mathematical formula when you sit down
with the attorney that is mandated by
the federal government because
bankruptcies federal court that to see
if you can repay I think the the means
test would likely throw you into a
payment plan you're probably not
qualified for a seven so it probably
throws you into that in your so
basically in a chapter thirteen you're
going to pay all of this or some
percentage of it and so I never really
understand why you would do a chapter
thirteen if that's the case why not
we're having a hard time monthly every
month there's no guarantee so if they
could
so don't pay it you're acting like this
is a debt consolidation bankruptcies in
the same categories of divorce it's what
you do after you've tried everything
else and the world has come to an end we
have tried everything I was a
stay-at-home mom and now working at home
ah my kids sleep my husband's working 40
to 60 hours a week worse we mean we're
making it now what is the what's the
about what's the balance on the passion
you're an 31,000 we and that's literally
how children of you higher myself okay
you're gonna have to get a used old
passenger van
you have to expensive a passion germane
I know I know and I even told my husband
that's what you were gonna say but the
thing is really and truly and I'm not
making an excuse the old ones don't have
headrests and they're so dangerous for
kids I mean their naps their necks can
snap in accidents because they don't
have headrest you're talking to someone
who used to sleep in the back window of
a car not buying it I'm not asking I'm
that you know you literally have made
this such a drama that your children's
lives are at risk
because the car doesn't have a headrest
come on darling I mean that's just
absurd seriously your family is
completely broke you don't even have
health insurance and you're talking
about headrests this is just it's crazy
so I think you can work your way through
this with some coaching but you're gonna
have to sacrifice some things I don't
think bankruptcy is gonna give you the
land of rainbows and skittles that you
think it's going to give you it might
mandate you know you can work your way
you can try it if you want but you
called me and I will tell you I would
move down in Van I'd sell the other car
get it by either for daddy
and I'd work it from there thanks for
the call hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh